make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking back up again
with the three
jokers yes this is the conclusion to the
three joker's storyline
right keep in mind that one of the
jokers is dead the clown joker
is the one that was killed by by jason
todd the criminal and the comedian are
still alive
but in this video we are going to find
out which one of these jokers is the
real joker and
it's amazing it's such a great review so
initially this kind of picks up with
like batman
and jason todd and barbara gordon kind
of conversing right about all the
information that they've seen
right you know the information that was
kind of brought together and the fact
that the joker wanted them to find all
this stuff right the three jokers wanted
these guys one of these these three to
find
all these things that are here and so
one of the things that was kind of
established in the last video
is that the jokers are created two of
these jokers were artificially created
in the sense that we have
one main joker and then he created the
other two and so the idea is that if
that's true then the question is
which joker is the real one right and
that's really where what they're trying
to figure out and one of the things that
jason todd says
is whichever joker is the real joker
once i find them like once i set my
sights on him there'll be no jokers i'm
going to kill him because
you're too weak to do it batman and when
that happens bruce wayne freaks out
right like he immediately loses it and
starts going after jason todd and the
reason why and this this is what's so
cool i'm gonna be honest with you guys
this is what's so cool i think this is
the best that jason todd's been written
in years and i'm just going to say it
but one of the things that batman gets
pissed out about
piss off about is like do you really
think that i haven't wanted to put a put
a bullet
in the brain of the joker right do you
think i really didn't want to kill him
after everything that he did after
what he did to you after what he did to
barbara do you really think i didn't
want to and the response of jason todd
is but you didn't
of all the talk that you have you didn't
do it you wanted to you could have but
you didn't and that's one of the things
that's interesting right like whenever i
make this point about how batman should
kill his villains people usually kind of
default to the slippery slope argument i
never really consider that a a good
argument it's a fallacy because one it
assumes that you can't control yourself
right it assumes that you can't say like
i'm just going to stop here the problem
with the slippery slope argument is that
if you apply it to across the board and
you say okay let's apply this slippery
slope argument to anything then we can
say okay you should never have a single
drink of alcohol in your life because if
you do it's a slippery slope and you'll
become an alcoholic
you should never smoke weed once in your
life because if you do it's a slippery
slope and you'll become a drug addict
right that's the problem with the
slippery slope argument right it assumes
that batman couldn't sit down and reason
and say okay of all the villains that i
have
joker is by and far the worst because he
just kills people indiscriminately for
reasons that don't make sense to anybody
but himself but has something to do with
the fact that he wants me to come and
find him and for every time i capture
the joker he'll kill a hundred people
before i get him so we should just kill
him and be done with it it assumes
batman can't define that reason right
batman can't say okay killing the joker
that's basically where it stops right i
can't justify
killing the penguin or anybody like that
because they're just they're they're
criminals right they do some pretty
shady stuff but nobody's as bad as the
joker is for the world's greatest
detective i have a hard time
believing he'd be unable to stop at that
line of logic so that
that's why i never really paid any
attention to the slippery slope argument
and just kind of ignored it because it's
the argument you make when you can't
make any other argument but
the crazy thing about this is that
batman basically says like you don't
understand right barbara gordon tries to
step in and kind of mediate things a
little bit but at the end of the day
they're both ignoring her it's jason
todd and batman and at the end of the
day batman's like you don't understand
you never have understood batman doesn't
say it in so many words but jason todd
does not understand the effect it had on
bruce wayne and the reason why
is because they're children to bruce
wayne they're as kids that's just that's
that's the that's just
the plain and simple statement of the
fact right sure barbara gordon has her
dad right she's got commissioner gordon
but batman sees them as children
especially jason todd tim drake and dick
grayson they're his kids
like he took them on as warts by all
standards of measurement he was their
father or father figure and he was there
to make sure that no harm befell them he
knew the risk that he was taking here
but he also understood that they needed
to have an outlet for their anger and
their vengeance and their desire to
destroy
they needed a good way to channel it and
the best way to channel it is to one
allow them to help him on his missions
but two to curb that desire for revenge
into a desire to make people's lives
better and so along the way jason todd
kind of seemed to have gotten lost but
jason todd was beaten to death and when
jason todd came
back and he was so angry at batman
because batman didn't kill the joker
batman wanted to
but he didn't because in his mind it
wasn't the right thing to do and so the
results of this is that you kind of have
this
little bit of a breakdown right the
batman runs over the criminal joker and
says he's very reminiscent of the joker
from the early days like the old bob
kane bill finger joker right like the
guy who was just really sadistic really
dark the clown of course they faced at
the aquarium and jason todd killed him
the comedian
is the one where you see him laugh but
there's just something there right
there's just kind of like this darkness
this dark sadistic streak behind the
laugh
and the smile and the eyes that just
shows this guy is the worst of them all
he's the absolute worst of the jokers
the most violent of all the jokers and
so because of that it's okay
one of these three is the original joker
maybe we already killed him in the
aquarium maybe it's the criminal
mastermind maybe it's the comedian right
maybe it's the most sadistic of them all
but whichever one it is
one of them is the real joker and so the
question of barbara gordon is maybe we
finally find out i think maybe we find
out the true origin of the joker and
at the end of the day like jason todd's
like maybe just some kind of a nobody
right
but where the questions asked like
batman do you know who the joker is
right like do you know his name the
response of bruce is no if i did know i
would have told you already and so what
you end up doing is picking up in the
aftermath of joe chill being kidnapped
right we saw that in the in the last
video that we did the last comment that
we did that joe chill was kidnapped from
blackgate prison while he was basically
going through medical treatment and
batman immediately wants to see a cell
now here's a crazy thing is batman's
going through these
these kind of books that were in the
cell of joe chill he came across
letters that joe chill wrote and none of
the letters were ever mailed out but
they were all made out to bruce wayne
and so where he
basically ends up going to see reverend
evans right the guy who essentially runs
the show kind of you know this this
priest you know who helps them find
repentance
he's not the warden but the person that
helps them basically helps prisoners
kind of discover who they really are or
allows them to repent or whatever the
case is that when batman's talking to
him he basically says you know he says
no like these letters were never mailed
because they were never finished you
know he dropped out of school when he
was 13. he was doing his best in his
classes here but his learning
disabilities slowed him down
right his inability to read at an
effective rate you know at an effective
level and that these letters that he
wrote were long before
he became ill because the thought of
batman and he kind of want batman wants
to deviate to the idea that joe chill is
still just a bad person
it comforts him and that's why batman
says okay so the whole reason he wrote
these letters is because he got sick and
he just wanted to he wanted to repent
right like he wanted to make sure he
didn't go to hell when he died and the
response of reverend evans is
no he wrote those long before he fell
ill a long time before he fell ill now
the other part of this is you pick up
with barbara gordon and you pick up with
with dick grayson while batman's you
know inside talking to the reverend and
dick grayson initially kind of hits up
barbara gordon and says look uh you know
i know i kind of screwed up here
right like i've put you guys in a rough
position but at the end of the day he
also tells her like we won't ever have
anything like that again and it's kind
of an important thing here because it
gives us a little bit of a softer side
of of jason todd and so it's a little
bit nuts there because
the question that reverend has is what
do they want with him right like why
take
joe chill in the first place right he's
a dying man like he literally has cancer
his days are numbered and he basically
says like i'm going to find out because
what he finds among all these letters is
one that was obviously written by the
joker
and it basically has a ticket to the
mark of zorro and so again that's at the
the the monarch theater that was the
show that batman and his parents or
bruce wayne his parents were going to
see when they died or
had seen when they died and so of course
barbara gordon and bruce wayne
and jason todd show up here and this
begins what's probably
the single greatest point in this whole
story the single greatest moment in this
entire story that when you have him show
up
a movie begins to play and this movie is
is basically like the comedian joker
talking to joe chill and saying okay
kind of picking out where we left off in
the last one
why did you really kill thomas and
martha wayne i've read all your letters
i've read the minister's notes you've
seen the light right your your
experiences and the suffering that you
cause
have touched your soul they've touched
your immortal soul and you have looked
to repent
all of your sins but answer something
for me why did you
kill thomas and martha wayne really what
was the motivation behind it now batman
of course ends up kind of making his way
through the theater as this movie is
playing and then finally comes across
joe chill who's currently being held by
the criminal and this is
cool because the criminal is not being
written as like a crazy goofy guy right
that was one of the cool things about
his character is he's methodical
he thinks he focuses that he that it
hurts him to laugh which i think is
probably one of the greatest additions
to the joker mythos
ever but what he says here is their
initial intention was to turn
jason todd into the new joker but the
problem with that is that jason todd
lacked sophistication and then they were
going to take barbara gordon but she's
got too much heart right so
he picked the killer uh he picked joe
chill the intention is to turn
joe chill into a new joker and it's one
of the things that's kind of nuts here
is because
while this little bit of a segment's
happening between criminal joker in
between you know batman that you've also
got like the comedian joker
doing that interview with joe chill they
recorded and they're putting on the
movie screen and joe chill you know to
kind of nip this in the bud real quick
so we can kind of focus on the meat and
potatoes of this joe chill the reason
why he killed thomas and martha wayne
is because he was struggling he was down
on his luck and he saw them and he
believed that people who were that rich
are the reason why he was that poor
it was their fault and so he wanted to
take some of what they had in order to
get himself back on his feet again right
and the result of that was that once he
got there and once he
essentially went to go rob them he
suddenly realized that bruce wayne's
there and before he knew it
the gun was going off right the gun was
going off and the result was that they
were basically killed but it wasn't
until
after everything that was going on that
he realized that thomas and martha wayne
which he already knew who they were but
they were actually people who were using
their money to make gotham city better
that they were looking to work against
those individuals who used their wealth
to buy politicians to make laws
in their favor things like that they
were the good guys and he killed two
people who were actually looking to make
gotham better who could have made his
life better but in his anger and in his
selfishness he kind of categorized them
all the same
everybody out there who's rich is the
reason why i'm poor right
and and there really isn't a direct
corollary between those two things
it's not necessarily because somebody's
rich you are poor right it's not
necessarily that way but joe chill
saw it that way and that's what led him
to committing the act that he did now
that admission will become much more
important later on down the line but
batman initially approaches
joe chill with the intention of freeing
him and criminal joker reveals he's got
his whole chest strapped with dynamite
now that's a classic move for the
criminal joker if you go back and you
read the old
the old bob kane bill finger stories
right do you ever get your chance you
know you can you can buy them on i think
you can buy them directly from dc
or you can grab them on comicsology you
can go read those super old batman
stories right batman number one number
two number three go read those really
old stories with the joker and that's
the kind of stuff you would do
and so you end up having you know
barbara gordon and jason todd
facing off against like these kind of
jokerized people right these jokerized
individuals who are out there but as
barbara gordon's facing off against a
couple of them they both get
shot and when she initially believes
it's jason todd she turns around and is
the comedian joker the one who shot her
right the one who shot her from killing
jokes still wielding that same camera
that he had his outfit's different but
he's still got the same camera and he's
like time for you to smile and so it's
like a great tribute to the killing joke
right it's like an amazing tribute to
the killing joke and so the the
motivation behind creating a new joker
and even the motivation behind the
creation of these jokers is revealed
when the criminal tells batman he wants
to be more
he needs to be everything to batman the
biggest issue that he has
with batman is he's not his main focus
now that's a that's a common point that
joker's had over the years
it's not something jeff johns is making
up on the spot that's been the
motivation behind joker for years for
eons and neons and eons that he wants to
be the one the batman focuses on he
wants to be the center of batman's life
he almost in kind of a sadistic and
screwed up way sees batman is like a
lover it's a dissatisfaction right the
fact that he doesn't have batman
focusing on him
in that way leaves him dissatisfied and
so initially batman's response is joe
chill's a sick dying old man
of what use would he be to you and
that's when criminal joker says i'm
willing to bet that this little bath
will put him into remission i'm willing
to bet if we dunk him in this water that
is going to cure his cancer it'll make
him insane
but it'll cure his cancer and he will be
one of us
and that's kind of the crazy thing here
right that's kind of the crazy situation
because right now this criminal joker
defines the concept of the joker as
undefined chaos we're just absolute
chaos there's no rhyme and reason
to us being like you don't see us as
like a form and a function right you
don't see us as we truly are that we are
the antithesis to you
instead you see us as just like crazy
guys who implement some schemes and do
some things and all hell pops off for a
little while and then things go back to
normal right like you capture us and
then we go to jail and that's basically
it but i need to be more
we as a joker need to be more and so at
that point like literally joker pulls
out a tommy gun goes to shoe batman of
course batman dodges out of the way but
in the process the ropes start to snap
the joker falls the lighter falls out of
his hand and ends up
ends up landing in this vat of chemicals
which of course turns us this great
huge chemical thing on fire and so in
that moment when when criminal joker
goes to fight bruce wayne you've also
got uh the comedian joker facing off
against barbara gordon and it's just
kind of like i've never i haven't had
this much fun in a long long time
and we're just getting started and when
part of the roof begins to collapse
and it doesn't quite kill barbara gordon
but when part of the roof starts to
collapse the comedian ends up bailing
out right he ends up taking off
and so you've got the the criminal joker
facing off against batman he goes to cut
the wire so that uh joe chill will fall
inside the burning chemical bath right
like the water has to be on fire in
order for it to fully effect right in
order for it to fully take effect but he
cuts him loose and then batman
saves joe chill and that's a crazy thing
is the criminal was not relying on
batman
saving joe chill that he was kind of
relying on batman's hatred of joe chill
to just let him die
right now i wouldn't necessarily say
that batman saves joe chill because he's
just like you know i don't kill don't
let anybody not you know i think it's
really more of
batman saves joe chill because he
doesn't want to deal with another joker
i think that's really what kind of goes
on here but of course he ends up
swinging back into action
going after the criminal again and then
once once the criminals temporarily
knocked out joe chill kind of looks at
batman as like i know who you are
they talk about you in blackgate and you
know what i did in this place
are you going to kill me and it's it's a
little bit ambiguous here
right it's a little bit ambiguous here
it's one of these things where joe chill
almost kind of wants batman to kill him
he i mean well i guess it's not really
ambiguous he says i deserve it but it's
almost kind of like he wants batman to
kill him but the cool thing about this
is joe chill
is exceedingly remorseful for his
actions and that's an important thing
because batman's initial response is
like no i'm not going to kill you and
that's when joe shows like i deserve it
i'm truly sorry for what i did
this combined with with batman's
knowledge of the fact that joe chill had
written these letters
before he became sick indicates that he
really is remorseful he's not remorseful
because he's on his last days
he really does feel terrible about what
he did because joe chill one
turned the life of bruce wayne upside
down and two doomed gotham
he made gotham what it is by getting rid
of thomas and martha wayne and allowing
corruption among the police and among
politicians and among the ultra wealthy
to run supreme he made gotham the way
that it is he single-handedly screwed up
the whole town and so it's kind of crazy
because of course the bricks start to
fall and then batman rescues him again
and you know he says thank you about as
like you're welcome but in that moment
the criminal pops back up again
right and he says like i'd hope to
extend this game more but now
we all go together right and gets ready
to pull this this stick of dynamite and
he's shot by the comedian like the
comedian shoots him in the head and says
and then there was one take me away
that's
arrest me and take me away now the big
question here is
why even kill him why even kill him in
the first place why
kill the criminal well the reason for
this comes after barbara gordon and
jason todd share a moment where
jason todd's kind of pissed about batman
just kind of sitting him back to the bad
cape that he also asked barbara gordon
is there really a chance about us
right because remember like they shared
a kiss and barbara's like no you know he
gets friend zoned basically he's like
you'd make a really good friend you know
i don't know what to tell you i don't
feel that way about you right he just
basically gets shut down
and so of course you know the two of
them end up going their separate ways
temporarily but batman starts having a
conversation with the joker and the
joker says like he's literally
see now after all of that drama don't
you feel better bruce right bruce wayne
robert gordon jason todd
you know i know but i don't care i'm not
gonna tell anybody
right the world can never know your true
name you might stop doing this
if i do right if i tell people who you
really are right you might quit
and that really kind of solidifies a lot
of what was established in scott
snyder's new 52 batman run that the
joker doesn't care about bruce wayne's
identity as batman that what he cares
about
is the cat and mouse game that they
chase each other around
they just go round and round and round
in circles the funny thing about this
is when batman asks the question what is
it that you want right the joker says
what do i want
certainly not what the others did the
clown your troubled robin put a bullet
in
all he wanted to do was laugh at the
suffering of others how
common right and the criminal that old
man was so delusional this whole great
big idea of creating a better joker well
that's just lunacy
right a defined joker one with a name
and identity that ruins the very
definition of me
that's why i regret making him or he
says
does he regret making me the reality of
this if i'm really a betty man here this
is the original joker the comedian is
the original joker and this comes in a
couple different ways like when batman
says what's the punch line the joker
says that's the point there's no final
twist
right not until i decide to put my knife
into your heart but he says the criminal
was absolutely wrong i am chaos right
i'm the devil i'm nothing and everything
to you
the joker is not the one who's broken
it's batman who's broken
all of this was basically my plan batman
was broken
by a greater pain than any of us could
ever inflict on you and so i convinced
them that making joe chill the new joker
would be
the best idea right the man who
destroyed gotham the man who destroyed
you
making him into the joker into like
another joker would
crush you right it would destroy you on
some level in a way that i never really
could
and the irony behind all this is he says
like you save the man who kills your
parents
who said the city literally spiraling
down into your inner despair
this man apologized to you which is
exactly what you needed to hear and so
because of me
your greatest wound has been healed and
so now i
can be your greatest pain i will cut you
i'll hurt you
oh i'll destroy your life in every
conceivable way that i possibly can
because now i am your only real focus
you're dealt with joe chill you dealt
with that that pain and that struggle
and that anger that you've been carrying
around all your life that wound
is now healed now there's the wounds
that i can create i can become
your source i can become your source of
anger and your source of pain i can
become the thing that you hate the most
in this world
i am now your main focus that was the
whole plan behind this right that was
the whole basis behind this it's an
amazing reveal but bruce wayne of course
goes to visit joe chill and and
basically accepts joe chill's apology
right the two of them actually end up
holding hands which is
a massive moment and he actually holds
the hand of joe chill
as he dies and so while batman didn't
necessarily tell joe chill in that
alleyway i forgive you
this is bruce wayne appearing to joe
chill as joe chill
needed for bruce wayne to appear to him
and say i forgive you for what you've
done
forgiveness is what bruce wayne needed
to heal himself and it's what joe chill
needed to finally be able to come to
terms with what it was that he did
george hill
of course dies and he ends up being
buried and then batman or bruce wayne
ends up traveling to alaska and he
basically says he kind of has this
little bit of a statement the world can
never know your true name you end up
having this bit of a conversation that
batman has with alfred now there is also
a letter that
that red hood leaves for barbara gordon
and says that like i want to make a
change right but i can't do that without
you
basically like it's a confession of love
it's a confession of love that he needs
barbara gordon the problem is like the
letter falls off the wall and ends up
being swept away by just some random guy
so she never gets the letter and jason
todd says i'll never bring it up if you
never say anything to me then i'll
assume you tore the letter up and threw
it away and i'll never ask you about it
if you never come to me and talk about
it i'll never come to you and i'll
assume that if you never came to me and
talked to me about it that you didn't
want to be a part of my life in that way
that you didn't want to love me in that
way that you didn't want us
to become something it's actually tragic
right it's insanely tragic right because
if i'm being honest as weird as it is
that robert gordon and jason todd kiss
because they're kind of like adopted
brother and sister i guess i could kind
of ship them
you know see them going together i don't
really know but batman ends up having a
conversation with alfred and the crazy
thing about this
is you basically have bruce wayne
talking to alfred and saying
i don't mean to sound the way that
people think i do but like i'm batman
right i knew the joker's name
one week after we first met i've known
his identity the entire time and then
you get these little moments these
little scenes
that come from the killing joke and
basically like you end up having the
wife of the joker where in the killing
joke the joke the explanation to the
joker's wife was that he died
the reality of this is that it looks as
though that's not true that she was
actually
sent away because it looked like she
would never ever ever be free of the
joker how the the nature of these two
guys consolidates with the way they were
depicted right because they refer to the
jokers like sir different things like
that doesn't quite make a whole lot of
sense you know but but anyway she's
basically talking to cops and you end up
having you know having her basically
escorted away essentially it looked like
her death was fate but she ends up
getting away from from
the joker before he became the joker and
she ends up traveling to alaska where
she's been this entire time
with her kid that she's raising and so
what this points to
and what and what i'm going with this is
the real joker out of all three of these
guys the real joker is the killing joke
joker the criminal joker
and the the the clown joker they were
created by the comedian
right they were created by him and that
they're not actually jokers they were
just two random guys out there who for
whatever reason the comedian joker
chose so the comedian is the true joker
right the origin of the killing joke is
the actual origin of the joker right and
it makes sense that's the one that fans
go with the most but that's where things
stand right now
killing joe joker that story is the
original origin of the joker he is the
original joker right so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain to make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
here